welcome to the presentation on
simplifying radicals so let's get
started with a little terminology out of
the way you're probably just wondering
what a radical is and i'll i'll just
i'll let you know let's see
let me get the pen settings right a
radical
is just that or you're probably more
familiar calling that the square root
symbol so with the terminology of the
way let's actually uh talk about what it
means to to simplify a radical and some
people would argue that what we're
actually doing is actually making it
more complicated but but let's see
let me erase that
so if i were to give you the square root
of 36
you'd say hey that's easy that's just
equal to 6 times 6 or
you'd say the square root of 36 is just
6. now what if i asked you what the
square root
of 72 is
well we know that 72 is 36 times 2 right
so let's write that square root of 72 is
the same thing
as
the square root of 36 times 2
right we just rewrote 72 is 36 times 2.
and the square root if you remember from
level 3 exponents square root is the
same thing as something to the one half
power so let's write it that way and i'm
just writing it this way just to show
you why how how this radical
simplification works that it's really
not a new concept
so this is the same thing as 36 times 2
to the one-half power
right because it's just a square root is
the same thing as one half power
and we learned from the exponent rules
that when you multiply two numbers and
then you raise that to the one-half
power that that's the same thing
as raising each of the numbers to the
one-half power
and then multiplying them
right
well that right there that's the same
thing as saying
square root of 36
times the square root of 2
and we already figured out what the
square root of 36 is it's 6
so that just equals 6
times the square root
of 2.
and you're probably wondering why i went
through this this step of changing the
the radical the square root symbol into
the one-half power and i did that just
to show you that this is just an
extension of the exponent rules it isn't
really a new concept although
it i guess sometimes it's not so obvious
that they are the same concepts i just
wanted to point that out so let's do
another problem
i think as we do more and more problems
these will become a little more obvious
the square root
of fifty
well the square root of fifty
fifty is the same thing as
twenty five times two
and we know based on what we just did
and this is really just an exponent rule
the square root of 25 times 2 is the
same thing as the square root of 25
times the square root of 2.
well we know what the square root of 25
is that's 5. so that just equals
five
times
the square root of two
now you're you might be saying hey sal
well you know that's that's uh
look you make it look easy but how did
you know to split 50 into 25 and 2. why
didn't i split why didn't i say that 50
is equal to the square root of
5 and 10 or that
50 is equal to the square root actually
i think of 1 and 50.
i don't know what other factors does 50
have well anyway i won't go into that
right now well the reason why i picked
25 and 2 is because i wanted a factor of
50.
i actually wanted the largest factor of
50 that is a perfect square and that's
25.
if i had done 5 and 10 there's really
nothing i could have done with it
because neither five nor ten are perfect
squares and same things with uh with one
and fifty so the way you should think
about it think about the factors of the
original number
and figure out if any of those factors
are perfect squares and and there's no
real mechanical way you really just have
to learn to recognize perfect squares
and and you'll you'll get familiar with
them of course they're 1 4
9
25
9 16
25
36 49
64 etc and maybe by doing this module
you'll actually learn to recognize them
more readily but if any of these numbers
are
the per are a factor of the number under
the radical sign then you'll probably
want to factor them out and then you can
take them out of the radical sign like
we did
up in this problem
let's do a couple of more
what is
7
times
the square root of 27. and when i write
the 7 right next to it that just means
times the square root of 27.
well
let's think about what other factors of
27 and whether any of them are perfect
square well 3 is a factor of 27 but
that's not a perfect square
9 is
so we could say
7 that's equal to 7 times the square
root
of 9
times
3.
and now we we based on the rules we just
learned that's the same thing as
7
times the square root of 9
times the square root of 3.
and well that just equals 7 times 3
right because the square root of 9 is 3
times the square root of 3
that equals 21
times the square root of 3.
done
let's do another one
what is
9
times the square root of 18.
well once again what are the factors of
18 well do we have 6 and 3 1 in
18. no none of the numbers i mentioned
so far are perfect squares but we also
have 2 and 9 and 9 is a perfect square
so let's write that that's equal to 9
times the square root of 2 times
9
which is equal to
9 times the square root of 2
that's a 2
times the square root of 9
which equals 9 times the square root of
2
times 3 right that's the square root of
9
which equals 27
times the square root of 2.
there we go hopefully you're starting to
get the hang of these problems let's do
another one
what is
4 times the square root of 25
well 25 itself is a perfect square this
is kind of a this problem is so easy
it's a bit of a trick problem 25 itself
is a perfect square the square root is 5
so this is just equal to 4 times 5 which
is equal to 20 right square root of 25
is 5.
let's do another one what's 3 times the
square root of 29
huh
well 29 only has two factors it's a
prime number it only has the factors 1
and 29
and neither of those numbers are perfect
squares so we really can't simplify this
one anymore so
this is already in completely simplified
form
let's do a couple of more
what about
what about
7
times the square root of 320.
so let's think about 320
well we could we could actually do it in
steps when we have larger numbers like
this i can look at it and say well it
does look like 4
actually it looks like 16 would go into
this right because 16 goes into 32 so
let's try that so that equals
7 times the square root of 16
times 20 right
well that just equals
7 times the square root of 16 times the
square root of 20.
7 times the square root of 16 square
root of 16 is 4 so 7 times 4 is 28 so
that's
28
times the square root of 20.
now are we done
well actually i think i can factor 20
even more because 20 is equal to 4 times
5. so i can say this is equal to 28
times the square root of 4
times 5
and the square root of 4 is 2
so that could just take the 2 out and
that becomes 56
times the square root of 5.
i hope that made sense to you and this
is actually a pretty important technique
i just did here immediately when i look
at 320 i don't know what the largest
number is that goes into 320. it
actually turns out that it's 64. but
just looking at the number i said well i
know that 4 goes into it so i could have
just pulled out 4
and then said oh that's equal to 4 times
80 and then i would have had to work
with 80. in this case i saw 32 and i was
like oh it looks like 16 goes into it
and i factored out 16 first and when i
took out the square root of 16 i
multiplied the outside by 4 and that's
where i got the 28 but then i reduced
the number on the inside i said oh well
that still is divisible by a perfect
square it's still divisible by 4 and
then i kept doing it until i was left
with
a
essentially a prime number or a
a number that couldn't be reduced
anymore under the radical and it
actually doesn't have to be prime
so hopefully that gives you a good sense
of how to do radical simplification it's
really just an extension of the exponent
rules that you've already learned and
hopefully as you do the module you'll
you'll get good at it have fun